yeah he's waving hello oh wow are you
going so cute
good morning today we're on our way to
pick up Casey's parents from the airport
they're actually in LA visiting us
because they were really eager to see
the new home they want to come over and
help us out so excited say there's mama
Chan she's walking towards
super fact in the 626 my parents wanted
some Chinese food tifos trading it well
I'm I'm dreading it is just you know
it's Chinese this is the most Kanto
place you're gonna find it's literally
called cafe table open up we got to a
sit at a bigger table now we're also
doing something that's a very hong kong
gonna do it's called dark or technically
we're sitting with other people right
now we left before they were ready to
leave how come because if you don't take
action they will never leave who the
women the women funny I have to get up
and leave so they leave who's the last
one always leave when we go eat with me
you why every single time when we get up
from my table he's like hold on in your
sit down he has to finish his drink I'm
just trying to get my money's worth
really you guys Chinese we have
brand-new carpet that's the only reason
why we are now Asian in this house
the one non-asian is the one telling all
the Asian yeah I'm like your shoes your
shoes this is the home excuse the
gigantic mess all those boxes there's
five boxes for a dining table I hope
yeah good help finally because I'm
always the one that has to build
everything you have any be handy I have
all the tools cooking I have my own
toolbox in here KP is the cook and then
me and mr. tan are gonna be a heavy
minute wanted to you have two o'clock
for you all the pictures if you want to
show my parents or house you see what
they think oh yeah Wow put that film on
the window yeah
so we thought I finish it because we're
gonna do both sides no one's gonna like
it says the amateur Warwick already hey
I used to be a wallpaper hanger you know
you know that
uh-hum capable three years I'll trust
your judgment then oh this is and the
light yeah we dream up these life that
night it looks really pretty
yeah it's that machine over there so Oh
Agis a sheet with his record player
we're starting up this have a guillotine
no it's an old school record player
literally there's no USB or anything on
our back room like brand-new bathrooms
so they just remodeled it and it raised
it up yeah they did a really good job
like you could tell MIT it like half
like Mickey Mouse at yeah you feel weird
you cursing in front my parents yeah
Isaac bathroom bedroom okay I would tell
you tonight that I need to see does
anybody ever come here usually but every
night in his room right yeah I wanted to
buy him like a beanbag chair but then I
said well here ya know final room of the
tour is the office
oh just naked actually is not that this
creates a nice thing okay hold it
I don't want it let me wait Faisal right
no no she won't
you just have to when you pick her up
you have to pick her up from near her
tail like back end so she knows her
there if you try to reach for her and
she can see your hands going towards her
then you risk getting bit that way
you had to present yourself to her she's
like okay
getting me a little nervous under she's
never acted like that was me yeah
haven't held her in a really long time
she's the only reason for her to ever
attack a human is if that human smells
like a rat oh you know you don't let it
spread have you touched her rat more I
bring a rat in crazy right she gets kind
of like you want a putter nope why she
won't do anything just put her back
that's what anything about my dad is he
doesn't like snakes and Chinese cultures
things are really really bad luck really
yeah
my mom's great see why couldn't you get
a little bit of that I'm holding hurry
up let's sure you you've come you've
caught a long ways welcome home baby boy
look mr. mrs. Chan are here how's school
good good mr. Chan is waiting for you in
there
it was a day get in trouble no job of
skill all right so you ready to do
homework yeah why are you turning TV on
okay okay
Isaac is tackling his homework with mama
Chen mr. Chen and I will tackle the
kitchen now there's all these boxes that
I need to the box and put away and then
mr. Chan's gonna be helping us build our
dining table yay Thank You papa Chan
you're welcome
progress being done we got four chairs
completed I got one more bucks - yay
mama Chen's been breaking down the boxes
getting stuff done I am heating up some
water because I'm gonna make them this
an elysian tea very good yeah like it I
made it all by myself
that's me cooking that's cooking from
scratch the first time I drink or eat or
taste anything that is made with you I
know it's so bad oh that's not true I
baked cookies last Christmas here that
count
all right now we're clearing out the
boxes what me and mrs. Chan did is we
brought in the dumpster I moved my car
here
we'll see how effective this is
all right so apparently I got yelled at
by the lady who runs this place that
lady with the dog the old lady she'll
die me she like what are you doing you
can just take a little dumpster and I'm
like oh you're right
so what I'm doing is something I don't
still lady ladies dumpster special I'm
fine over here
all the boxes are cleared pretty good
ending to the day ma'am so tired I can't
even suck at this done and I didn't even
know I bought a dining table that had a
lazy susan in it
pretty cool surprise Thank You Papa Chan
I can't wait till KC comes home when you
see this hi what's up I see the boxes
you guys tied up father
hey you can't peek what oh all right
close your eyes come here
hold on turn okay walk up bed and I'm
gonna look down then okay look down one
more set okay wait up open oh wow look
accidentally bought it with the lazy
susan oh I know it's little clothes your
parents did such an amazing job helping
me yeah yeah yeah look look down there's
no more boxes Wow behind the boxes a
story behind the box oh wait till I tell
you I'll tell y'all camera is too long
I haven't cuddled with you in so long
she's I can miss you right she's like oh
you're warm let me wrap myself for my
mom it's funny cuz I told David she
loves to cuddle he's like no you're dumb
she's just using you for your warmth I'm
like I know but I want to tell myself
that she's cuddling with me